the jurgen experience this is what's so
beautiful man you're you're
sick you're in the universe i'm in the
universe you know dave rubin's in the
universe ben shapiro's in the universe
alex jones is in the universe
the people are there's a whole new
structure
it we have we're out of control we don't
know what the [ __ ] they're doing they're
going to try and control
all of us one way or the other yes but
the internet
we pretty much have that we got free
reign we do but we do we got it now
we have a lot but there's also a lot of
censorship i mean you don't
need any of that you set up mastodon you
got your own network you don't social
you don't need yeah
let's be realistic when it comes down to
it joe
for sure but there's a lot of people
that had prominent voices that are
silenced
yeah right but they're they're now very
prominent in a much smaller circle i'm
i'm prominent in a circle it got bigger
once i visited you
and i hope that yours got bigger as well
and
the two can be completely unaware of
each other and crossovers happen
and and the network starts to grow it's
a whole new way of communicating
no i understand that and i i i know you
appreciate it i do what's happening
but there's certain people that just get
banned forever
from some social media platforms yeah
but not from other ones that's my point
yeah but in this environment shouldn't
we take into account like if you were
gonna ban someone if you're gonna like
say
listen uh there's a rational
expectation that a person should be able
to
say your beliefs are not in aligned with
theirs they're gonna kick you off this
business that they own
sure as long as the bit like but when it
gets to be youtube and you got 31
million
subscribers and how many hours 500 hours
a minute
500 hours a minute yeah it's it's such a
pipeline
like you can't tell me you're really
monitoring this thing correctly it's not
possible no
of course it's not that's why we have
everything has to be
distributed it has to be but i think
there should be much
more stringent rules on whether or not
you can ban someone
oh i so don't give a flying
[ __ ] about what facebook or youtube or
google do
it's so unimportant in the vast scale of
what we can do i understand that
and i agree but in the individual
the person who has the youtube channel
who has uh earned this position yeah
and got screwed and got screwed that's
not fair no
it's something it's also not rational
that they could just do it they don't
have to go through a lengthy court
proceeding
they could just remove your income a
couple of things i believe on the
commercial platforms that we're talking
about in this case
the problem is the business model
advertisers don't like controversy
advertising has gone down drastically
since the word coronavirus or covid19
was blocked because they didn't want
controversy so that's the reason why
these networks do it
they i don't think they yes there's
people who ban
conservatives specifically but that's
because of the
uh elite messaging system the mainstream
media also the pharmaceutical
industry a lot of finance is this
message
so that's what advertisers want look at
the [ __ ] that the nba
are and nike and how they kowtow to
everybody yes
i said it look at how they kowtow and
what they will and will not allow
um so that's all money based very
capitalistic by the way that's totally
cool
but now we go to
the way you and i were raised at you
what doing
you're 50 you're 52 53 no yeah i'm 56
tomorrow
basically halfway dead no i want to be
106.
i got i'm going to be 98 that's my
that's my target 98.
yeah why that number i don't know well
my gran my brain my grandparents both
lived to 98 my
paternal grandparents the the reason why
i brought up gavin
is that i think that there i've i have
had a couple podcasts with him
and people have had like weird
conversations with me about it
and i've said this is one of the things
that i said was like look that guy's
mostly fun
yeah mostly fun and like anybody that
does wild [ __ ] you can get lost in the
woods and if you get lost in the woods
of
race or or or or whether or not uh
people should be able to label the uh
uh able to do drugs or whether or not
people should get paid a minimum wage
that's a livable wage
you get lost in the woods in any
ideology and it becomes a problem let's
go back for whatever reason
when when someone shifts one way or
another and we conflict with those
those ideas we never give anybody any
room for
for just being a person most of the time
i've been around that guy
he's a nice guy right but let's go to
the basics of how i
there's two things i was taught growing
up sticks and stones will break my bones
names will never hurt me secondary okay
i will def i mean that's created in the
depression hormones are [ __ ] terrible
and i'm so mean
exactly and i can pinpoint when that
happened too
so we had that and then the
i don't like what you say but i will
defend to the death you're right to say
it these are the
two core values that that's so important
that's what i'm talking about that's
what i'm talking about with everybody
whether it's
alex jones we're the core values and
that is our constitutional deal
yes that's the deal and this includes
louis farrakhan
this includes everyone everybody
everybody everybody mitch o'connell
everybody
tell me what you think bro exactly
everything right all of them
episodes of the joe rogan experience are
now free on spotify
that's right they're free from september
1st to december 1st they're going to be
available everywhere but after december
1st they will only be available on
spotify but they will be
free that includes the video the video
will also be there
it'll also be free that's all we're
asking just go
download spotify much love bubba